[Musique]
nathalie sarraute
ce n'est pas dans cette pièce quoique on
travailler non d'habitude je travaille
toujours dans un café où près d'ici
enfin je reste beaucoup dans cette pièce
l'après midi ils doivent cacher pourquoi
je me sens mieux toujours dans un café
parce que je suis complètement isolé
puisieux heures devant cap habituel où
puis je n'ai rien pour me distraire dans
un coin que le salut ou café jouée sans
complètement seul puis riendeau qui me
sollicitent issue bien obligé de mettre
à travailler c'est justement ce bruit du
café de présence d'autres gens mais qui
ne sont totalement étrangers possibilité
de me concentrer beaucoup plus grande
seul chez moi dans une chambre le
feuille blanche
c'est quoi pour vous c'est difficile
est-ce que vous traînez mais très
difficile pour moi j'écris très
lentement et j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
je crois que c'est très important de
sortir de chez soi et que l'écrivain qui
reste chez lui et toute la journée il me
semble qu'il doit y avoir de plus
grandes difficultés à se mettre au
travail
et puis il ya une sorte de sentiment de
culpabilité dans le monde entier tout le
monde sort saby ça de chez soi par tous
les temps et qu'à travailler alors je me
donne à ce moment là l'illusion de faire
exactement le même travail que tous ceux
qui vont dans les bureaux je ne dirais
pas à l'usiné ce que je ne comparerai
pas ce genre de travail avec le travail
très dur de lusignan fait disons un
travail de bureau
justement d'ailleurs tout bien fait
sensation de culpabilité qu'on à être un
écrivain mais quand je suis en fait
elles n'étaient pas travailler et écrire
c'est finalement une façon d'adopter
l'opinion des autres oui je sois un peu
parce que du dehors les autres ont
vraiment l'impression qu'on ne fait rien
mais en fait physiquement qu'il crée
fatigant mais c'est très fatigant jeu
quand je sors du café même autrefois
quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais très
fatigué véritablement épuisé enfin je
tremble presque fatigue mais c'est une
sorte de travail qui ne se voit pas et
puis c'est un travail qui n'est pas
exigé qu'ils ne répondent à aucune
demande c'est que ce qui me donne aussi
l'impression de ne pas être du vrai
travail dans entre la vie et la mort un
beau livre d'ailleurs vous parlez du
travail qui devient quelque chose qu'a
fait danser terrifiant c'est à dire j'ai
essayé d'en entre la vie et la mort de
montreux le travail sur le texte dès
qu'il est en train de se faire j'avais
appelé le livre entre la vie et la mort
notamment parce que le texte est
toujours entre la vie et la mort lente
au parce qu'il n'est pas assez travaillé
tantôt parce qu'ils les trous il meurt
et par cette espèce de
duvet de tremblements et qui devrait
avoir de vie tout simplement
et alors souvent le travail tu cela
oui et en même temps l'absence de
travail ou le manque de travail un push
cela va paraître il faut que ce ne
soient pas écrasés par le langage
vous cherchez quelque chose avec et dans
le langage que personne n'avait entendu
encore chaque mot est brun des quantités
de vagues de de sensations de pulsions
de désir de terreur par exemple et dans
votre dernier livre vous les entendez
tout se passe à la campagne dans une
maison de campagne
l'endroit le plus tranquille du monde il
y a deux hommes qui regardent un objet
et les enfants de l'un d'eux sont à un
autre étage et puis peu à peu on tombe
dans des camps se rend compte qu'il se
passe des choses tout à fait
désastreuses pour c'est pour surtout
pour l'un de ces hommes qu'il y a là des
peurs des crises des choses redoutables
terrifiante et qu'en fait nous vivons
constamment sans le savoir
alors vous voyez par exemple s'émeut un
terrifiant où désastreux je ne les
emploie jamais moi même ça ne vient pas
l'idée de le dire quand je travaille
puis c'est quelque chose qui se passe
quelque chose qui est là et qui me
paraît faire partie de l'existence c'est
un moment de l'existence au tout d'un
coup quelque chose s'ouvre est alors
quand on le développe comme ça au
ralenti on y voit toutes sortes de
choses évidemment un troublante au
pénible mais sont que des instants
mes désirs pour atteindre sinon pour
arriver à faire se dilater toute cette
façon d'un instant pour rester aussi
longtemps ont souvent pendant tout un
livre sur un temps est très court
il faut une concentration extraordinaire
c'est à dire il faut s pas grossir c'est
regarder cela même à travers des vins
verres grossissant
et puis voir comme ça se déploie comme
au cinéma quand on montre un mouvement
au ralenti le décomposer dans tous les
petits mouvements qui le composent
c'est ça qui est intéressant en réalité
quand on regarde de plus près ça va loin
ça atteint certainement aux racines
mêmes lettres là aussi ça oui c'est
évident il est évident et c'est pour ça
que je parlais du terrain vous avez
affaire aura cousin chacun de nouveaux
certainement saddam et je ne sais pas je
pense que et bien tu as christique
intégrer ses romans policiers qui me
font honte à moi une peur tellement
terrible que quand j'avais lu le meurtre
de roger ackroyd j'étais très jeune à ce
moment là et j'avais j'étais seul dans
l'appartement le téléphone sonnait canoë
fait traverser les couverts je n'ai pas
les réponses très très bon public ses
forces pour les romans policiers c'est
pour ça que je peux pas en lire
elle n'avait sûrement pas peur du tout
je suis un petit peu comme ça c'est pas
dur gaubert non ça me paraît naturel
tout ça nathalie sarraute
le propos de cette émission c'est de
parler du livre que vous êtes en train
d'écrire
au lieu de parler toujours d'un livre
terminé
et au fond qui est un peu mort pour soi
mais je vous prends dans les offres
c'est vraiment la chose la plus
difficile
oui de parler de quelque chose qu'on est
en train de faire je crois on a peur
même d'en prendre trop conscience dès
qu'on en parle on se met un peu au
dehors
n'est ce pas on survole un peu pour en
parler et puis moi dans ce que j'écris
c'est très difficile de trouver une
intrigue quelque chose que je puisse
raconter si on veut c'est plutôt quelque
chose qui ressemblerait à une oeuvre
politique c'est à dire que là il n'y a
que du ressenti que du ressenti ce n'est
pas du tout une reproduction d'une
action qui se déroule dans le tarn une
reproduction d'une réalité visible si on
veut alors je ne peux pas le résumer je
peux on a indiqué quelques thèmes chaque
mot qu'on dit on a l'impression que
c'est une terrible rétrécissement un
aplatissement vous voyez par exemple je
lisais récemment dans un livre sur joyce
que quelqu'un avait dit à jaws qui la
met beaucoup un livre et joy cela dit
vous pouvez vous me citer un passage par
coeur il a dit non alors comment
pouvez-vous me dire que ce livre on
espère tant qu'il n'aura pas vu un
morceau de texte ou ce qu'il y aura dans
ce texte
quand on parle comme ça d'un livre alors
tout c'est énorme effort que l'on a fait
se résume à peu près peu de choses
en langage comme sa critique si on veut
enfin là je peux dire que je suis parti
comme toujours dans mes livres de
quelque chose d'extrêmement simple c'est
une sensation encore une fois j'ai
l'impression que c'est moi qui suis
peut-être seul à l'éprouver la face et
l'impression que nous avons chacun du
dedans d'autres l'univers entier une
dette non sommes nous sommes tous nous
ne sommes rien
c'est ce personnage si je puis dire
cette conscience que je montre dans mon
livre en est tellement
persuadé que ça colore toute son
attitude toute sa vision du monde et
c'est ça le un des thèmes enfin le point
de départ il ne se sent pas être
quelqu'un
oui il n'est rien ne sais pas comment il
est comme maintenant je ne sais pas du
tout quelle image jeu projet je suis
absolument incapable même de l'imaginer
elle meurt il est dans cette situation
où il est venu signer rien et tout
autour il voit des personnages ça c'est
toujours man man hantise dans tous mes
livres des personnages qu'on voit et qui
sont tous quelqu'un est dans ses
personnages à tout moment se défont ils
voudraient les voir tout simple comme ça
mais à tout moment il ya des failles des
fissures les personnages se mettent à
bouger ils deviennent eux aussi ses
infinies ces univers entier que chaque
être humain il y alors là dessus se
greffe autre chose c'est que cette façon
de voir les gens en personnage créé des
discriminations entre les êtres et à les
gens intelligents ya l'egypte il ya les
imbéciles et on arrive à cette tricherie
qui a donné son titre à tout le livre la
livre s'appellera entre guillemets
disent les imbéciles c'est qu'au lieu de
juger une idée par elle même on se on
essaye de la tuer de l'écraser en
trichant et en disant c'est ce que
disent les uns disent ils au lieu de
regarder les idées d'où qu'elles
viennent
c'est en somme un acte terroriste c'est
un acte fascistes vous n'êtes pas tout à
fait alors ça donne le titre à l ouvrage
et tout l'idée est que quand quelque
chose se présente il faut juger l'idée
par elle même et pas cherché d'où elle
vient
le plus grand génie peut avoir des idées
stupides et il faut s'élever contre elle
est au contraire quelqu'un qui a la
réputation de ne pas être intelligent
peux te dire quelque chose qu'il est
extrêmement enfin il ya toutes les
possibilités tout l'été les virtualités
les êtres c'est très incertain quand m
parce que vous supprimez justement tous
et ses contours factice qu'il y a autour
des gens et en fait c'est très difficile
j'imagine pas faire ça doit être
vraiment c'est terriblement difficile
parce qu'en fait le langage jusqu'à
présent est fait pour étiqueter les
choses pour donner ses contours et pour
faciliter d'ailleurs un peu ce
terrorisme qui vient de cela tous les
côtés et de tous les atouts bien tous
les niveaux il y en aura avec ce même
langage du fait pour faire ça vous vous
détruisez c'est ça qui était globalement
juste ce que vous dites il ya tous ceux
très difficile de se servir de langage
du langage qui est déjà figées et qui
est fait comme vous le dites il vient
pour recouvrir des catégories tout fait
de se servir de lui précisément pour
détruire toutes ces catégories alors il
faut prendre par exemple énorme cliché
les saisir à la gorge les secouer au
moment ils sont en train d'asséner de
tomber de tout leur poids sur quelque
chose qui bouge qui est en perpétuel
mouvement
mais c'est à dire je pense à quelque
chose que dont nous parlions et cette
culpabilité de l'écrivain qui a
l'impression que socialement il ne
remplit pas tellement rôle puisque c'est
un rôle qui ne lui ai pas demandé vous
avez des ventes est non seulement il ne
lui ai pas demandé mais il n'est pas
recommandé non pas dangereuse qu'on fait
avec le langage là c'est une chose
justement qui fait ébranlé certains
fondements et certains disent en
commodités qui servent enfin vous
partiez fascisme tout à l'heure ça peut
aller jusque là
donc le travail de l'écrivain est un
travail finalement qui a un rôle très
profonde pas immédiat mais ce n'est pas
qui n'est pas innocent et qui n'est pas
comment dirais-je
planes passe dans des machines annoncé
mais ce nouveau livre nathalie sarraute
celui que vous êtes en train d'écrire
pourriez vous un dire au passage ce si
gentil
oui enfin s'est arrachée oui comme ça du
texte du contexte alors c'est toujours
un peu je suis une bête je me connais je
suis bête
avez vous jamais entendu quelqu'un dire
ça et bien sûr voyons on l'entend à
chaque instant dieu que je suis bête je
suis vraiment une bonne bête de me
laisser faire comme ça non je vous en
prie ne trichez pas vous savez bien
pourquoi on lui dit je vous le demande
sérieusement c'est très important
quelqu'un at il jamais pu penser de lui
même qu'il était bête ou carrément un
imbécile ça tout de même pas à tout de
même pas ça tout de même pas à ça pas un
imbécile
ça on ne le peut pas mais alors au alors
et qu'est-ce qui regardez comme ils
tremblent quoi alors calmez vous il nous
arrive à tous à chaque instant de penser
intel est plus intelligent que moi c'est
déjà reconnaître non pas à bout ça ne
vous arrive pas non ça n'arrive pas ça
ne peut arriver à personne pas pour de
bon intel a plus de dons ça oui
intel a du génie intel a des lumières
sur ceci ou cela que moi je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas sa culture je ne possède pas sa
science mais qu'ils soient plus
intelligents que moi
non impossible il était étonnant alors
dites moi vous croyez vraiment aussi
intelligent que dix ans d'écart vous
voyez il le croit qui ne dit mot consent
incroyable mais vrai il le pense
vraiment ça commence à devenir drôle
mais dites nous donc pourquoi
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser
qu'avez-vous donc fait pour pouvoir vous
permet
être rien je n'ai rien fait vous voyez
de qu'elle est sans la moindre gêne la
moindre honte
on dirait qu'il en est fier je n'ai rien
fait ils nous défient un sage qui se
tient la tête haute sous les moqueries
de la populace ignan un martyr de la foi
vous voyez justement c'est un moment où
les gens se moquent de lui oui parce
qu'ils disent qu'au fond chacun de nous
ressent je crois enfin que nous sommes
incomparable uniquement par able et
surtout que nous sommes l'univers anti
si je pense que je suis un imbécile
ce que je suis bête je ne peux plus
vivre l'espace jeu devient aveugle sourd
tout ce qui me dirige qui fait que je
vis n'est ce pas devient sujette à
caution et je ne peux plus il ya
d'ailleurs un autre passage là dessus
dans le livre oui
ou quand il était adolescent il entend
plaider camarades dire de lui qu'il
n'est pas intelligent partir de ce
moment là il ne peut plus réfléchir à
rien puisque tous ces idées sont
frappées de nullité
tout s'effondre c'est ça tout s'effondre
alors il va trouver son père le supplie
de me dire si oui ou non c'est vrai sont
perdus sont les autres sont des petits
imbéciles pour un moment ça le rassure
et puis après ça ne suffit pas qu'on
dise des autres se sont désinvestis sont
les catégories dans lesquelles ils
n'arrivent pas à entrer
chacun a droit de repenser le monde et
on n'a pas le droit de dire que cette
idée là est stupide parce qu'elle vient
d'un imbécile
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est et
j'avais été un jour frappé c'est ça qui
m a donné l'idée de ce titre devient
sous la plume d'un philosophe à propos
d'une pensée de jeunes c'est lui qui
sait ce que disent les imbéciles je me
suis dit comment ce qu'il ose un seul
permet le titre disent les imbéciles a
certainement prêté à beaucoup de
malentendus
[Rires]
je l'aimais entre guillemets parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui dise ah oui et comme
on ne va pas les 10 mais on pourrait
croire que c'est par ce genre de
sottises une énumération de stupidité la
vie l'écriture pour vous nathalie à
rhodes
c'est très lié vous pourriez construire
une vie sans ici je m'ennuierais les
rires quand je crois que toute personne
total est passé c'est d'ailleurs je
crois que peut-être le seul privilège de
l'écrivain musique on travaille choisi
lens est un travail très très
privilégiée dans l'enfance et en même
temps un travail qui est mal rémunéré
qui comme on le disait et qui n'est pas
exigée mais la plupart du temps au
départ
en tout cas c'est mon cas je le faisais
parce que ça m'intéresse pas je ne
pensais pas même à ce moment là que ça
paraît très que ce serait au début quand
j'ai commencé à écrire main j'ai fait ça
comme on fait ses premiers poèmes un peu
pour soi pour exprimer vous montrer on
sent que je compte sensation très fort
vous sentiez toujours la nécessité
d'écrire l'assemblée absolument faisait
pour vous c'est un moment si je mens
c'est d'ailleurs que je ne trouverai
jamais je n'aurais jamais dû public je
n'aurai pas de lecteur je ne sais pas
mais en fait ça m'intéressait je ne
pouvais pas ne pas le faire oui c'était
sa vie va nous pousser tes deux flamands
et c'était une véritable nécessité
oui je comprends très bien et maintenant
que tout est tellement changé que vous a
plu dans le monde entier est bon il ya
des livres écrits sur vous livrer via
des quantités de choses qui sont allumés
j'ai souvent l'impression que pour vous
ce n'existe ni ça court ça passe à côté
ce traiteur et oui c'est quelque chose
qui est tout à fait loin et au dos rond
pour aiguiller dire que ce sont les
oeuvres les plus admirables n'ai jamais
été écrites ça ne changera rien au fait
que le passage que chiant toit en train
de faire est raté et qu'il est mauvais
mais que vous n'écrivez pas ça est ce
qu'il ya vraiment une maman vous
n'écrivez pas
est ce que quand vous êtes ailleurs que
dans ce café par exemple vous écrivez
est-ce que vous avez l'impression de ne
pas travailler
oubliez à ce que vous pensez toujours à
ce texte
c'est drôle c'est par à coup ça me
traverse l'esprit à un moment le plus
inattendu
je suis en train d'écouter quelqu'un où
je suis même en train je parle à
quelqu'un et c'est comme s'il y avait un
autre tiroir dernière qui s'ouvrait ge
il ya une phrase par exemple qui me
vient tout d'un coup à l'esprit qu'il
pourrait me servir demain
oui ça peut ne passait pas ce midi c'est
plus que cette personne vous dit n'a
rien à voir avec ceux se déclenche comme
ça où est ce que c'est en fonction de ce
que vous avez entendu vraiment ou bien
ce que c'est une annonce assez
d'éclairage ça doit se poursuivre
ailleurs vers le manga parce que ça
vient un moment où ça n'a aucun rapport
avec ce qui est en train de se passer au
même avec ce qui est en train de akwa
chez en train de penser mais j'ai
l'impression penser autre chose c'est à
ce moment là quelques fois que j'ai
quelque chose qui me vient à l'esprit
enfin je veux dire que tout de même un
travail qui se fait tout le temps
probablement même inconscience
je le crois mais par exemple est ce que
c'est pour vous un lieu ce texte
manuscrit
c'est un endroit que je dirais pas un
refuge mais une sorte de je ne sais pas
comment dire peut-être deux royaumes
dont on peut dire que quand je suis là
devant je retrouve mon texte par exemple
après un voyage ou une tournée de
conférences une chose là l'entraînement
je n'y pense pas vos coûts koch prise
tout à fait aux doors à l'étranger
surtout ça m'intéresse tout ce que je
vous aime bien quand je reviens j'ai
absolument je me replonge immédiatement
je rentre chez moi je suis chez moi puis
c'est tout de suite que je suis dans ce
faux pas même plusieurs jours pour me
remettre au fond être chez vous c'est
aussi être de votre travail c'est celle
là que je suis je crois vraiment je me
sens le plus sûr
oui c'est à dire que me sens toujours
bien en fin mai fait une sorte de corps
au brise
dans la ma coquille dans mon élément si
on veut et par exemple je peux fait un
moment comme en ce moment un an nous
avons cette conversation est bon il ya
quelque chose autour de nous qu'est ce
que c'est un moment comme ça dans mon
atelier
c'est complètement en dehors ce passe
comme ce quelque chose d'agréable une
présence quelque chose parce que
d'amicale d'affectueux surtout parce que
vous êtes là viviane que nous sommes des
amis alors c'est très agréable c'est ça
devrait être encourageant si on veut
mais cela n'a aucune influence sur le
travail du lendemain je veux dire que
demain je me retrouverais exactement
aussi seul à mon point de départ en face
de difficultés qui me paraîtra comme
toujours insurmontable je crois que rien
venant du dehors ne peut aider ni les
encouragements ni même une compréhension
qu'on montrera pour ce que j'ai déjà
fait demain par exemple demain vous
allez vous retrouver devant votre
feuille
oui parce que ces difficultés elles
viennent de la substance même sur
laquelle je travaille
personne ne peut y venir n'est ce pas me
donner un coup de main ça ne sert à rien
rien il n'y a aucune aide à espérer du
phare fille de votre travail
je crois que finalement en travaillant
recommence en persévérant cette espèce
de sensations qui échappe à rivera
exister à travers des mots
[Musique]